hbo's game of thrones prequel house of
the dragon has a killer cast a new
writer's room and the approval of george
rr martin himself but will that be
enough to bring back the game of thrones
fandom after the controversial season 8
finale here's everything you need to
know before you see house of the dragon
on march 30th hbo announced the most
important piece of news about house of
the dragon on twitter the game of
thrones prequel will release its first
episode on sunday august 21st following
its hbo debut the episode will be
available to stream on hbo max we can
safely bet hbo will follow this release
plan for each of the 10 episodes that
comprise season 1 of house of the dragon
in february george rr martin announced
on his blog that filming on house of the
dragon was finished he wrote i've seen
rough cuts of a few of them the writing
the directing the acting all looked
terrific martin then tipped his cap to
co-show runners ryan condole and miguel
shapochnik as well as the cast and crew
for all of their hard work saponchnik
told the hollywood reporter in october
2021 that although they were standing on
the shoulders of game of thrones and
needed to maintain a respect for the
original the prequel has its own tone
that will evolve and emerge over the
course of the show he continued we'll be
lucky if we ever come close to what the
original show was so we're just putting
our heads down and getting on with it
hopefully it will be seen to something
else but it will have to earn that it
won't happen overnight
although specific concrete plot details
about the series are still relatively
sparse we can infer some larger details
from the novel it's based on in george
rr martin's own words fire and blood
covers the seven targaryen kings from
aegon the first aka aegon the conqueror
to the regency of aegon iii aka aegon
the dragonbane along with many of the
people they meet during that time warner
media's march 30th press release
includes a simple log line for the
prequel series first season based on
george rr martin's fire and blood the
series set 200 years before the events
of game of thrones tells the story of
house targaryen
hbo max released a teaser trailer for
house of the dragon on october 2021
revealing that the series will not take
place 300 years before game of thrones
as originally intended but 200 years
instead the short teaser offers a quick
glimpse of the hand of the king shot of
king viserys targaryen on the iron
throne holding the sword known as
blackfyre alison's hightower moving
worriedly through a crowd holding a
dagger and a couple of targaryens
standing on the beach we also get a
quick flash of lord coreless velarion
looking pensively off into the distance
and we see his entire family making a
grand entrance into some high profile
occasion there are also shots of fights
and a jousting tournament and we see one
of the targaryen princesses walking
slowly towards a much bigger and scarier
iron throne matt smith's damon targaryen
is the only actor heard in the teaser
handing out the teaser with dreams
didn't make his kings
dragons did we don't get any dialogue
between characters or other expositions
but the quick visuals show enough
intense and beautifully shot moments
that take viewers through season one and
hopefully beyond
the first official trailer for hbo's
house of the dragon delivers on the
explosive cutthroat narrative behind the
targaryen legacy and deadly civil war it
opens with an older rhaenyra overlooking
the cliffs of dragonstone she's
currently the ruling princess of the
island a location viewers will recognize
as daenerys refuge in game of thrones
season seven i was born at dragonstone
not that i can remember it
we also see rhaenyra's gold dragon
flying over king's landing with the
princess on her back viewers also find
ancestors from house stark and baratheon
pledging their loyalty to king viserys
in the throne room after that we're
treated to a staggering jagged and book
accurate iron throne showcasing the
thousand blades of aegon's enemies they
were supposedly melted down by dragon
giant balerion the black dread the
trailer appropriately ends in a roar of
dragonfire frightening an awestruck
prince daemon targaryen enticing
audiences to return to westeros in
august lastly a new official trailer
that dropped on july 20th unveils even
more of the series premise we see more
of the unrest with king viserys choosing
his daughter as his successor over his
brother damon of course these older
times weren't as progressive as daenerys
and cersei's so we see that a lot of
people of westeros aren't too fond of
having to kneel to a queen instead of a
king
hbo officially released the first poster
for house of the dragon promising a
reign of dragonfire when the series
premieres august 21st on hbo max the
striking poster features a full look at
the heir to the iron throne and dragon
rider rhaenyra targaryen with her
enormous dragon her valerian features
mira daenerys with whom she also shares
a fierce destiny and a determination to
rule westeros the poster also includes
our first look at a freshly forged iron
throne and rhaenyra's royal red and
black targaryen gown meanwhile the
menacing dragon foreshadows the
devastating targaryen civil war the
dance of dragons which the series
centers on
one question is on the minds of loyal
book readers will belarian the black
dread be one of the many dragons
featured in the new prequel series fans
of game of thrones will remember
valerian's giant dragon skull that
cersei lannister destroys with her
dragon killing weapon what they may not
know is that the black dread was once
written by king viserys when he was a
young prince the enormous beast goes on
to melt down the many swords of aegon's
enemies with his deadly dragonfire and
according to in universe folklore that's
how aegon the first created the prized
iron throne according to the world of
ice and fire valerian unfortunately died
of old age in 94 ac ac meaning after
conquest referring to aegon the first
the new series will begin around 129 ac
when the targaryen civil war started
therefore it's unlikely we'll see
valerian in house of the dragon at first
we've seen possible flashbacks in the
trailer so it's possible the black dread
may return into ceres's
the author of the a song of ice and fire
series has given a seal of approval and
then some by even citing some
improvements to his original source
material the beloved author wrote on his
blog i've now watched rough cuts of 9 of
the 10 episodes and i continue to be
impressed i cannot speak to the special
effects many of which are not in yet but
the look of it is great and the acting
the directing and writing are first rate
as for the changes he states for all you
book fans it is my story sure there are
some changes from fire and blood we
could not present three alternative
versions of every major event not to
keep our sanity but i think ryan condole
and his writers made good choices even
some improvements
entertainment weekly confirmed house of
the dragon would be filming in england
instead of northern ireland like the
original game of thrones series however
the news that the prequel series would
be filming in the notable leavesden
studios in watford was even more
revealing the production site is famous
for other iconic warner brothers
projects like the harry potter series
and more recently the batman house of
the dragon also returned to film at
singular game of thrones locations in
spain watchers on the wall shows the
production crew returning to catharez
and trujillo which bowl served as king's
landing locations for thrones season
seven and will again for the new series
kathra has also served as old town where
sam trained to become a maester which
house of the dragon could also
potentially return to additionally
watchers reports the series filmed in
portugal and cornwall england and the
cornwall shoots featured a few esteemed
house of the dragon cast members
game of thrones series composer rameen
javadi is confirmed to return to
westeros and compose the score for the
highly anticipated house of the dragon
javedi is responsible for many of the
iconic soundscapes behind major
characters and of course he also
composed the game of thrones intro music
it wouldn't be an exaggeration to call
it one of the most iconic tv theme songs
of its era and he will surely create to
fiery new anthem for the prequel series
elsewhere on hbo romain javedi's work
can be heard on westworld season 4 where
he puts his own unique twist on hits
like billy eilish's bad guy and
metallica's enter sandman one of the
main reasons this particular show was
produced instead of any of the other
game of thrones spin-offs in development
is because of the solid foundation laid
out by george rr martin's firing blood
the sprawling prequel novel chronicles
the targaryen dynasty from aegon the
first the conqueror to the dance of
dragon civil war that ripped the royal
family apart by fire blood tooth and
claw
martin's book is the blueprint for hbo's
newest dragon pack series and could
serve as a worthy successor to the
original groundbreaking show the house
of the dragon is also similar in concept
to brian cogman's rejected spin-off
series that hbo chose not to produce
kog'man wrote the game of thrones series
bible and was often referred to as the
keeper of the mythos on set he ended up
writing 11 episodes over the series run
including standouts like kissed by fire
what is dead may never die and a knight
of the seven kingdoms
after a poorly received final season of
game of thrones even the most hardcore
fans are cautious to return to westeros
according to its many detractors season
8 rushes character arcs of the series's
most important characters and double
down on spectacle instead of substance
creators david benioff and db weiss who
adapted the hbo hit from george r.r
martin's song of ice and fire series
found themselves met with massive
backlash fans were so outraged by the
final season that a petition was formed
to remake it entirely which has since
amassed nearly 2 million signatures the
season was so rejected by fans that
martin himself felt compelled to comment
and cited the toxicity felt from
negative fans i don't understand how
people can come to hate so much
something that they once loved how has
everything become so toxic martin has
also recently promised his ending will
be quite different than the shows and is
even a credited co-creator and executive
producer on house of the dragon with the
author himself seemingly more involved
in this new series fans have a good
reason to be optimistic
while d.b weiss and david bennie offer
creating new content at netflix
emmy-winning director miguel chapochenic
is returning to westeros on a full-time
basis shapochnik famously directed the
jaw-dropping brutality of game of
thrones season 6's the battle of the
bastards as well as season 8's feature
film length episode the long night which
showcases the surviving heroes battling
against the undead white walkers for
house of the dragon shabbat will direct
multiple episodes as well as act as
co-creator and executive producer
co-creator ryan condol serves as writer
with george r.r martin who is returning
to wright for the first time since
season 4 of thrones alongside a new crew
of promising riders this fresh writer's
room would seem to ensure that house of
the dragon will indeed have a different
tone from the original series
the targaryen sigil has three heads the
house of the dragon has three main
dragon riders king viserys rhaenyra and
daemon all climb the respective backs of
their dragons and rain fire down upon
their enemies though viserys never takes
flight on another dragon after the death
of valerian rhaenyra and daemon will
provide plenty of fiery sky scenes in
the upcoming prequel daemon's dragon
karaxis is something of a different
beast from the aforementioned other two
flying fire lizards nicknamed the blood
worm kraxis was first tamed by aemon
targaryen the first the red dragon is
described in the books as the fiercest
of all the young dragons in the
dragonpit and fearsome and no stranger
to blood and fire with karaxis at
damon's disposal and when the dance of
dragons begins we can certainly
anticipate an onslaught for anyone who
gets in his way including his knees the
pure valerian rhaenyra
as the saying goes
they say every time a targaryen is born
the gods toss a coin and the world holds
its breath in the book the dance of
dragons is a brutal civil war that
viciously pits family against family and
dragon against dragon for the iron
throne the war nearly wipes out the
entire targaryen family leaving only a
handful alive by the time of the events
depicted in game of thrones after king
viserys dies the kingdom is divided on
future ruleship with everyone plotting
their own secret scheme and playing a
conniving game of thrones and as we all
know
when you play the game of thrones you
win
or you die
there is no middle ground viserys names
rhaenyra his heir but as the trailer
states men would sooner put the realm to
the torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
before there was the house of the dragon
hbo confidently planned to move
thousands and thousands of years away
from the world of westeros as we knew it
the origin prequel dubbed with many
nicknames like the long knight and the
seemingly official blood moon would
explore the roots of the sinister
zombie-like beings the white walkers it
was also intended to dive into the
magical lore of the children of the
forest who helped ran in season 4 of
game of thrones this first attempt at a
prequel series reportedly titled blood
moon was set to star naomi watts and the
pilot was written by jane goldman it was
unfortunately cancelled after hbo spent
a reported 30 million dollars on the
first episode when former warner media
entertainment chairman bob greenblatt
viewed the episode in greenblatt's
account when i saw a cut of the pilot a
few months after i arrived i said to hbo
boss casey bloys this just doesn't work
and i don't think it delivers on the
promise of the original series and he
didn't disagree which actually was a
relief
recently the hollywood reporter broke
the news that a jon snow spinoff is in
development at hbo with kit harrington
reprising his role this brings a grand
total of other throne spin-offs
currently in development excluding house
of the dragon to eight possible new
series according to deadline there are
three live action series being explored
including 10 000 ships nine voyages aka
sea snakes and flea bottom additionally
a dunkin egg prequel series was
announced hopefully these will have
better fates than blood moon and they'll
follow house of the dragon hbo three
animated series have also been announced
though george r.r martin gives words of
caution to fans anticipating all the
spin-offs making it to air the
television rider is no stranger to
unaired pilots and though his lips are
sealed tight he gives several tidbits
and other possible titles on his blog
with eight potential spin-offs in
various stages of development it's safe
to say we won't have to worry about
leaving westeros anytime soon
while we won't see any game of thrones
characters alive in house of the dragon
they'll certainly be there in spirit
there are already striking parallels
between dragonstone residents rhaenyra
and daenerys from their shared valyrian
features to their fiery determination
and resilience the envious and entitled
daemon eerily embodies viserys iii's
vile spirit and his silver blonde hair
is reminiscent to the pompous prince the
sea snake lord corliss velaryon and his
wife princess rhaenys targaryen will
also conjure memories of similar
characters like euron greyjoy and cersei
lannister the sea snake commands the
largest naval army in westeros while the
targaryen princess was also denied the
iron throne because of her gender reinus
is a dragon rider who is surely angry
about being dubbed the queen who never
was she'll command her dragon and the
dance of dragons while the sea snake's
origins will also be further explored
fans can also look forward to returning
to familiar locations like king's
landing harren hall dragonstone and
possibly old town and dorne if the novel
fire and blood is any indication of
what's to come
game of thrones fans will remember the
harrowing adventure sir jorah mormont
and tyrion lannister took through the
ruins of valeria in season 5 of game of
thrones this mysterious location may
have a significant influence on the
house of the dragon due to its deep
connection with the history of the
targaryens the prophesied disaster is
the reason for the targaryen's initial
landing on dragonstone and their
alliance with house valarian
a city of a thousand years
and all that men had learned
the doom consumed it all alike though
not much is known about the catastrophic
event we know many of the great city of
valeria's precious secrets like magic
were forever lost in the doom the
devastating eruption consequently sent
essos into chaos and gave the dothraki
an opportunity to claim an abundance of
land surrounding the dothraki sea the
ruminous event was so powerful it even
killed dragons and is the reason why
there are so few left in westeros could
the house of the dragon eventually
revisit this critical point in westeros
history only time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]